le calme avant la tempête
les danseurs de tout d'abord amène le
public dans leur art de john style né
dans les années 90 en hollande
des performances fait de saut de
quelques secondes qui ont inspiré le
collectif la horde voir des jeunes
garçons parce qu'il ya très peu de
filles dans la communauté s'est exprimé
comme ça sur les réseaux sur internet se
réapproprier leur corps alors que
souvent ils sont dans des îles sont en
tout cas isolé d'institutions
culturelles et donc ici s'émancipe se
réapproprient leur corps pour faire un
art qu'est la danse
et c'est cette rage cette exaltation qui
nous a tout de suite fonctionné avec
marina jonathan depuis 2014 le collectif
explore cette discipline un film des
performances et une création
chorégraphique tout d'abord une heure de
danse survoltée tout d'abord c'est un
clin d'oeil aline hardcore qui me dira
record tout d'abord donc hardcore
jusqu'à l'os et qui harnik nos accords
les danseurs ils sont onze tous
autodidactes et européens pour la
plupart avec tout d'abord ils sont
passés des réseaux sociaux à la scène de
la danse individuelle au groupe
la plupart des danseurs sont droitiers
et quand je suis arrivé pour danser avec
les autres danseurs j'étais gauche et
une autre a fallu réapprendre à danser
de l'autre côté donc ça a été très
difficile
vous avez plusieurs pas de base et vous
avez plusieurs mouvements clefs qui
reviennent en fait qui sont là qui
établit une espèce de base commune pour
les chômeurs et ces mouvements là en
fait et ba par exemple en france sur les
appels d'un certain nombre en pologne
d'un certain nombre en russie pour eux
le pas de base le plus utilisé n'est pas
le même qu'en france des différences qui
se reflète sur scène avec urgence et une
certaine fureur de vivre
mais le collectif laisse parfois la
place à l'individualité avec une énergie
plus douce mais contagieuse